he's brent musburger the legendary
broadcaster almost 50 years in
broadcasting and now venturing out on
his own the lead broadcaster managing
editor at vegas stats and information
network Brent good to talk to you again
hi Dan my friend I'm doing great how you
hey feeling feeling terrific what a
weekend we've got in college football
let me just give you one stat down for
the last four weeks here at the South
Point sports book and I'm sure some of
the other books around the city of Las
Vegas college football has attracted
more gambling dollars than the National
Football League and this week is going
to be one of the biggest of the year
three top ten matchups can't wait to get
start what's easier to pick college or
pro college football not even close
college football just because there's
more games well that would be one thing
obviously and you can find some
mismatches and as you cannot even
against the point spread the National
Football League I've got a couple of
injuries in the big contests over the
West Gate Super both you behind 450 now
do you pick five games a week on
Wednesday against a static line that
doesn't change one of the entries that I
have be sent to underwater not even at
500 the other one is in the top 400 and
is about six games out of the lead right
now and doing very well and a full
disclosure I'm not the offensive
coordinator of that one I'm the one
that's underwater so it is very
difficult picking winners against the
spread of the National Football League
great listen I hope the Supreme Court in
December after the hearing allows the
state of New Jersey states rights why
shouldn't have atopy the only state that
allows single game sports wagering I
hope the Supreme Court realizes that I
expect them to overturn the lower
court's decision and then I expect about
20 other states to join in we have too
much money going off store where it is
not regulated what I found out here in
Las Vegas is that sports wagering is
regulated is looked upon every day by
the by the powers that be and that's
what it should be we shouldn't have
these
dollars flowing offshore to an
unregulated betting market this has to
Jake can you see a scenario Brent where
you get to you can go to a stadium and
at the stadium you can place a bet that
there's a room there that you can have a
credit card on file that you have to be
21 years of age show an ID but you could
go in and have a betting lounge at all
these stadiums do you see a scenario
like that down the road perhaps they've
got similarities over in the UK you can
go into their stadiums is that the
Premier League the one the one thing
that I would argue against strenuously
these do not accept credit cards they do
not accept credit cards here in Las
Vegas when you go up to make a sports
bet or if you're wiring in a half a
million dollars as they did prior to the
big fight out here between the Greger
and may Wizards its cash okay you you
pay up in cash when you make a bet and
they pay you back out in cash no credit
cards we don't want to go in that
direction but otherwise yes your
scenario because right now right now you
can go to let's say an NBA game right
again or even an NFL game you go in with
your digital phone you can make a bet
right now offshore with that unregulated
market here in Las Vegas you can make a
better go over and watch the Vegas gold
a nice play and the National oculi I
tested it out one night when I was over
there watching the game I could have bet
during the game a different over/under
so the digital world is not going away
and those who argue morally or
corruption and we've got to protect the
integrity that the ship has sailed the
digital world has changed the universe
for better or for worse I don't want to
get into that debate but it's not going
back you're not putting the genie back
in the bottle we're talking to Brent
Musburger who called the 1988 Miami
Notre Dame game that became known as
Catholics during Conda
versus convicts what do you remember
about going into that game
it was unbelievable then the environment
around us out then you know the one real
regret that I have is when NBC god bless
him they took control of the Notre Dame
home games and I wasn't able to go back
in after that to do it's one of the
great studies and this
was special you have to remember and
this was another game I did with Arab
Parseghian and Jimmy Johnson and the
canes trampled Gerry Faust down in Miami
in his final game as head coach now
let's be perfectly honest Faust who had
done a great job of masculine high
school in Ohio was in over his head as a
head coach but he was such a wonderful
man he was so great to be around and he
loved children loved him to death and
the Canes pounded on him and they never
let up they had to put a hundred of if
they could have believed it I know Jimmy
Johnson license around here was a
terrible scheme they brought it down
themselves plotted a ball of the butt
nonsense
that cane team wanted a Barry Notre Dame
that particular day and at some point in
the fourth quarter in a quiet
distinguished way Iowa Parseghian as my
analyst said I would have thought that
Coach Johnson would have shown more
compassion well there was a great writer
down in Miami at the Herald Edwin Pope
and he unloaded our secret at Notre Dame
went to the front page of the Miami
Herald and came on Lou Holtz then came
in era and I did it gave up with
Minnesota olds for the coach of
Minnesota with the only time in his life
that era ever asked me to please stay
out of the room but I knew what was
going on arrow was talking to Holtz
about coming to South bed then the good
fathers allow us to go out and get some
hurricane football players again I'm in
there okay so we go to this lady of that
day and stop then and this youngster
walks up to me and hands me the t-shirt
Catholics versus the convicts I've still
got it in some stories box up at Montana
again I'll never forget it I go in we're
all set we're getting ready to the game
you know we got a prepackaged this a pre
packet and then I hear there's a
fistfight in the tunnel
we got to throw everything out so it
starts a Ishmael was directly involved
or whatever happened in that tunnel but
they've changed they've changed the
procedure for allowing visiting players
and home players to come out of that
signal color and stuff then ever since
it was it was a great day it was a great
football game okay and it came down to
Cleveland Gary lunging to get a first
down around the goal line and he didn't
get it to this day it's the only time
that
Jimmy Johnson would get mad at me when
he sees me because Patton and I both
said he didn't have the first down
and it was Notre Dame football and then
in the end it came down to a 2.2 per
shift was knocked out it was you know
it's funny not every game who I remember
obviously but this is certainly one that
that still resonates but make no mistake
make no mistake about this this was not
a bunch of privileged children at Notre
Dame these were very very good football
players and they could slug it out with
anybody and they did that day against a
very talented Miami team Jimmie
Johnson's run down in Miami was
remarkable the blade's brothers and
urban and all those guys Testaverde all
of those guys loved being around him I
don't think that this is quite Catholics
versus the convicts - I know because of
that game I think it's a little bit
different yeah you know Mark Richt is
not the same style as Jimmie Johnson
Brian Kelly's got fired his belly he's a
little bit like Lou Holtz we've seen him
lose it other side it's gonna be a heck
of a football game this is the first
time this is the first Saturday of this
year that I'm Miss Lee not be in the
arena that's a game outlets a call did
Miami create swagger in college football
that that team that hair of it
well they enhanced it no question about
it they would come into the arena the
day before they would dance around the
logo at midfield they would taunt the
other team my favorite my favorite of
all time they go into Florida say they
go into Tallahassee okay that here's
Michael Irvin a Benny plays the big
tough guys now Florida say that football
players - you know so Benny and Michael
decided to by God that horse I'll say
he's not coming out he's not coming out
on renegade and he's not throwing that
damn flaming spirit that's not happening
I'll watch we're gonna stop that horse
there was about 20 of the Canes out
there at midfield and so their camera
gait at a full gallop I got to tell you
he hits about the 35 or 40 yard line you
never saw a cane players move so fast
like okay
the Chiefs got right there middle II a
banging down came the flaming sword yeah
I
love being around those canteens and
also they played an arena where there
was a where was a home-field advantage
that's the old Orange Bowl out of the
heart of Miami that was a great great
setting a hard rock will not be quite
the same it was noisy last week forever
the Virginia Tech game they got a roof
over to keep more of the noise in there
now and the Canes listen their best game
of the year was last week as for Junya
Tech they held that portunity tech team
to 10-point stand but I'm gonna remind
everybody this week in Vince Lombardi
old guy likes me we love Vince Lombardi
what do we like the power sweep it is
back with Notre Dame they run as a
different direction
okay they run it more to the left
because their left tackle is a top-five
NFL draft choice he seals up that edge
against the Reds rusher then they bring
these two powerful guards through and
they create this angles for the running
game it's gonna be a treat to watch I
know that ABC is gonna have isolations
on it's pulling guards it is magnificent
it's that throwback it's old-school
Miami to win this game has got to stop
the power sweep otherwise they have no
chance whatsoever this is the best
rushing attack that I have seen this
year Notre Dame averages and
unbelievable 330 yards a game run the
vault and it's going to come down to
that will you ever call another game you
never say never
however I'm very happy Reese and I love
talking about all the games you know I
can now talk more about the NBA it
wasn't coming the NBA over TSP and I can
talk about the National Football League
in my days which you mean a Greek you
know we're trying to give information to
help people we know that there's
hundreds of thousands of people like to
bet on games
we don't sell play should probably go
broke if you if you pay me a nickel for
one of my picks but we like to give out
information try to help people along the
way
I love a lot of folks out here in Las
Vegas I've known them forever the
bookmakers are great John a fellow down
at the win knowing him for a long Chuck
Esposito at the space it's all these
guys are buddies so I love being out
here but I never ever say never
we mission
great to talk to you hope you're having
fun certainly sounds like but thanks for
joining us
you got it take care have a great
weekend thanks dad
that's Brent Musburger the Vegas stats
and information network also my guys in
the desert 3 to 5 p.m. Pacific weekdays
point-spread Saturday and Sunday 8:00 to
10:00 a.m. Pacific on Sirius XM 204 for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]